I'm James Powell you can tweet at me at
don't use this code if you like this
presentation or if you have any
questions about what I'm about to
present I want to give you a disclaimer
usually I don't know if any of you have
seen any talks I've given before this is
I think the 26th or 27th now maybe
thirty fourth or so PI data I've
presented at given a lot of PI data
talks usually they're complete nonsense
something fun but very silly this talk
as you can see from the title is
intended to be useful and I thought that
I wouldn't be able to convey to you
through the material in the talk please
don't use this code so instead I decided
to grow an absolutely absurd mustache
because nobody can take this seriously
with this thing in place so that's my
disclaimer let's get started
so this talk is about a very simple
scenario that I think we've all
encountered at some point in our working
career we're working somewhere one of
our colleagues left they left us with
some large code base maybe fifty
thousand lines of code and now it's your
problem to deal with what they left
behind and what I want to go through in
this talk is a simple guide for what you
do when you're put into that situation
on this is a very complex and very deep
topic and in the span of 45 minutes I
don't know that I can give you all that
you need to know about it but I wanted a
touch upon a couple of common points
because this is something that I faced
all the time in my work and I wanted to
give this to you as a mixture of a
couple of simple techniques and a little
bit of theorizing around the topic to
try to understand how can we break down
a problem that immense and so we'll do
this very basically step one find a new
job there is no step two thank you for
much anybody have any questions okay so
I heard a bunch of questions in there
let me see if I can answer some of them
one of them is why lines of code I mean
it's a very imperfect metric but I think
it's a very understandable metric it
really doesn't you know when we say
fifty thousand lines of code what we're
referring to is a very specific thing
it's not five million lines of code it's
not five lines of code it's something
that's a sizable problem that you might
expect would be within your capability
to pick up but in practice turns out to
be very difficult and in fact I think I
heard somebody say actually this is
a comment than a question but doesn't
really depend what fifty thousand lines
of code we're dealing with a colleague
of mine told me when when we were
discussing this talk that they had
written a hundred thousand lines of code
in a month that's ridiculous I mean
that's enormous productivity I think the
industry average that people have been
talking about since the 70s is average
programmer writes about a hundred lines
of code a day and if you think there's
about two hundred working days in the
year that means that the average
programmer outputs to twenty thousand
lines of code and this statistic albeit
a very flawed statistic is a Sicily
that's used to promote languages like
Python because the thought is would you
rather write 20,000 lines of Python in
one year or 20,000 lines of C in one
year
but what you can think is obviously it
does depend on what the 50,000 lines of
code are if for example you're given a
50,000 line code base and you run c-loc
on it and it shows that it's 20,000
lines of HTML and 20,000 lines have
reacted 10,000 lines of Python that's a
very different problem to solve then if
it's 50,000 lines of pure Python
obviously some type of code like HTML
you have other techniques to refactor
that but since it's not active code
there's a certain limit to the
complexity that an individual line of
HTML can contain it's a lot easier to
deal with so for the purposes of the
further questions that we'll be
answering for the remaining 42 minutes
that we have in this talk let's just
talk about Python we'll talk about the
kind of code bases that we interact with
day to day which are large Python code
bases usually what you might call an
application or a system as opposed to
core library now for some of the
analyses that I'll talk about in the
further questions that I will be
answering will I write I ran some of
these on some code bases that I've used
for work and some common libraries like
matplotlib that we used depending on
what kind of code base it is whether
it's application code system code
whether it's a library code some of the
metrics that we look at and some of the
techniques that we look at will or will
not work now one really interesting
question that I did here on the cab ride
over here this morning was somebody
asked me why don't you use the machine
learning algorithm to try to understand
the code that you have and I thought
that was a very interesting topic
I think that the topic of using some of
the rich data analytical tools that we
have in order to understand the code
that we're producing is something that
doesn't really get a lot of coverage I
think one of the reasons for that is if
you think about it when you're writing
code you're essentially modeling and
irreducible complexity the the unending
profundity of the real world into a semi
mathematical model typically when you're
using a machine learning model you're
dealing with a much more concrete
mathematical entity it turns out that
machine learning models can give us some
very interesting results where those
mathematical entities correlate very
closely to real-world tangible things we
can think of like image recognition you
know the pixel value can somehow
correlate to recognizing an entity or
not but if you think about it it would
be very difficult to thoroughly
mathematize the functionality and the
requirements and the complexity of a
codebase in such a way that you could
feed it into a machine learning model
and get something out of it although
it'd be an interesting exercise to try
and if somebody wants to tweet at me
after I don't know uploading a codebase
into a machine learning model and trying
to predict what the next line of code
would be that would be very interesting
if you could figure out a way to
actually structure that problem now one
question that I think I heard among all
of the questions was this is actually
happen and I think this has happened to
me a number of times every time I just
found out their new project or a new job
in a couple of cases I wasn't able to do
that and so I've had to deal with it but
if you think about it if somebody sends
you an email and they send you five
lines of code you just use those five
lines of code there's really a generally
incompressible amount of complexity that
you could see in five lines of code
maybe you could refactor those five
lines of code into one library call
maybe you could fix the syntax a little
bit maybe there's a corner case and so
those five lines of code turn it to
seven or ten lines of code but the five
line of code number is really not that
much that you have to deal with in fact
you can read through it either decide to
use it decide to refactored all in the
span of about an hour if somebody gave
you 50 lines of code or an email saying
hey we want you to use these 50 lines of
code you could probably just rewrite
that code you might not even read
through it you might just ask what does
this do and in the span of about a day
you could probably just rewrite it from
scratch and ignore what you were
provided another question that I think I
heard was what's the big deal
I mean fifty thousand lines of code
but if we continue that thought process
if we think about five hundred lines of
code what happens when somebody gives
you five hundred lines of code well that
might have some hidden complexity it
might have some hidden state it might
require access to some resources like a
database might have a very complex
runtime context and so most likely what
you would do is you'd read through it
you'd rewrite it and the entire time
would take about a week and you begin to
see that there's an interesting
expansion of effort because in a very
productive day almost certainly all of
you in this room have written two
hundred three hundred four hundred five
lines of code but I would I would doubt
that in a very productive day would be
very easy for you to rewrite that in
just just a single day so you can see
what took you maybe one or two days to
write may end up taking somebody else
one week to rewrite one week to refactor
one week to understand now if we extend
that further for 5,000 5,000 lines of
code that becomes maybe a month long
process where you'd have to read through
every line maybe try to understand
what's going on in that code maybe write
some tests around it and I think the
5,000 line of code target is about what
you see when people give talks about
refactoring via test-driven development
typically they're talking about small
libraries where you can easily identify
what the functionality is where the
complexity generally is and write a
couple of tests around it and over the
course of a week or two start to
dismantle that complexity and understand
what's going on
I think another common question that
comes up is why not ask for help with
this and if you think about it if you
were given five hundred thousand lines
of code or five million lines of code it
is very unlikely that a single person
has written five hundred thousand lines
of code or five million lines of code
and honestly if you're given five
millions of lines of code written by one
person not only should you quit your job
but you should quit your job
sort the stock of that company and run
as far away as possible
convince your friends to quit your to
quit that job or alternatively start a
consulting company just sit wait around
until the company comes to you because
they're hopelessly there just in a
hopeless situation having to deal with
five hundred thousand lines or five
million lines of code written by
somebody maybe hire the original author
who wrote this and cash in but generally
what we see for large code bases like
that is
the work product of multiple people and
so there's usually some form of
documentation there's either a mailing
list there's either a SharePoint site
there's either a wiki there may be in
encode documentation in the form of
comments there may be some remaining
artifacts of the development process the
problem is oh let's see if we can get
back to where we were the problem is
when we oh that's a nice thing live
editing our slides right there we go the
problem is when we deal with something
in the middle this this five five 50,000
line of code level because when you're
dealing with 50,000 line of code it's
possible that it's the work product of a
single person done over the course of
maybe one to three years if you think
about that metric a hundred lines of
code per day that's about two to three
years worth of work that somebody could
have done because it's the work product
of a single person doesn't necessarily
mean that it's not completely critical
to the operation of the business unit or
the company itself but it does mean that
that person could have encoded a number
of hidden requirements into this code it
means that there could be a lot of
hotspots where there's some small corner
case in the business model that's being
addressed and it's entirely possible
that there are no documentation and
there's no tests whatsoever in that code
base because since it was a work product
of a single person they could keep all
of the work in their mind and they
didn't need documentation they didn't
need tests they just kind of knew how
the thing worked and the most cynical
and unfortunate part of it is they may
have set unreasonable expectations
because think about it the work product
of one person that's five 50,000 lines
of code
they could have turned around code fixes
or new features in the span of maybe a
week or a couple of weeks when you
inherit this codebase this is now beyond
what you can read through in the course
of a week or a month
it may take you as much as a year to
actually read through and understand all
the complexity in that code but when
that gets handed over to you it from a
business perspective you go from
somebody who was able to turn around a
feature request or a bug fix and
anywhere between a couple days to a week
so now somebody who has to say
well I can't do any work on this system
until I have spent a couple of months to
read through and rewrite it and so you
have to be incredibly strategic in order
to manage these expectations if you're
not then you're suddenly seeing enormous
degradation in the business process
because you can't respond as effectively
as the original author and yet you have
none of the resources none of the tools
none of the built-in knowledge that
original author had and so I think the
only other reasonable question is we
know that if we're put into the
situation we should find a new job but
even in as good a job market as we're in
you may not be able to find a job that
quickly and so what do you want to do
while your table searching well if you
don't mind just getting fired I would
say take your vacation time or just kind
of send a couple of emails or just slag
off the old author as much as you can
but if you feel a little bit of
obligation to your former company and
you actually want to do something that
maybe helps them before you book it and
you get out the door there is maybe a
couple of things that you can do and I
would say that if you were to think
about this process one of the main
things you want to do is you want to fix
your expectations the original author
was able to work within this very
degraded software development lifecycle
this very degraded soft development
process where there might not be
documentation there I might not be test
but they're still able to be effective
and they set a set of expectations that
you will not be able to meet and so one
of the most basic things that you want
to do to set those expectations is just
find something to run and run it this is
absolutely critical if you cannot run
the code there's very little that you're
gonna be able to do other than slag off
the old author and update your resume
and one of the unfortunate things is I
have been given code bases where I could
not run them to say I'll just run the
test suite there may not be a test suite
I'll just run a sample app there may not
even be one I've been in situations
where the code runs on a remote machine
that has access to specific databases or
specific resources and I can't just sit
at my console and import a module and
run it and so the absolute most critical
thing to do is find some runnable
context in which this thing works in
which this thing runs from completion or
if it's a long-running tool run you know
you can start it up because once you're
able to run it you can
then begin to try to dismantle its
complexity unfortunately Python is such
a dynamic language that you're going to
be you're gonna find it very difficult
to understand a Python code base unless
you apply dynamic instrumentation and
dynamic analysis techniques especially
in the hot spots in the code where
something kind of hinky is going and
those are the hot spots which you might
be able you might be obligated to fix a
bug or to extend functionality one of
the things that I also try to do is I
try to iteratively narrow my focus as
much as possible when I first was given
an assignment like this when I was very
junior at one of my first jobs my goal
was to thoroughly understand the
codebase and to be able to confidently
say everything about how it worked and
within a week of no reportable progress
I realize that's not going to work at
all in this degraded scenario of you
being given a lot of code with no
support you need to kind of disabuse
yourself of the notion that you're going
to have mastery over this codebase and
you need to try to find as narrow a
portion of this code base that you can
do something with as possible you may
never be able to understand the entirety
of it but there are a couple of general
rules of hand that I've seen with
regards to these kind of code bases most
production code bases especially when
you're talking about an application and
not a library most of the time less than
20% of that code is interesting most of
it is just application of some core
library or some technique to some
business problem and 80% of it's just
application of the business problem and
you don't really need to touch that and
generally most of these code bases about
50% or more of it works and so there is
some core of that code base that's both
interesting and either needs new
features or is buggy and needs to be
fixed the problem is how do you find
that and what I find often is if you
want to kind of break it down in a large
code base like this there's some portion
of that code that you might say is dumb
code it's boring code there's some
portion that's smart code or interesting
code the boring code is code that is
generally very static it's very
repetitive it's typically applications
of some core tools or libraries and
there tends to be a lot of it when I say
static what I mean is
no Python is an incredibly dynamic
language we know we can do monkey
patching we know we can have first-class
functions we can we do all sorts of
things that make it very difficult to
statically analyze our code which is why
tools like my PI or pep 484 type type in
ting have limits to what they can
provide to us similarly it's it's
relatively difficult to make generalized
refactoring tools in Python like the
Java community uses all the time
typically the majority of the code base
is static it's boring it's just people
calling static calling functions where
we know lexically what that function is
where you can trace that function back
to the import and there really isn't
this dynamic dispatch or this
indirection that you'd expect from the
interesting code the smart code or the
interesting code the minority of this
code base and very likely the place
where you need to dig in and do
something tends to be very dynamic so
there might be some code which is using
configuration in order to generate what
functions get called that dispatch may
not be determinable statically you may
need a runtime context to even figure
out where the code goes for example if
you look at how set up pi and dist utils
work try to figure out what the process
is from going to the from the entry
point of a setup py to the actual code
that runs or if you look at a tool like
clique or any of these other command
line generators I actually try to figure
out how much code runs between you
passing in a single argument to
determine what command gets run and the
underlying function similarly for web
framework like flask or Django just try
to as an exercise try to see how far
there is between when the the web app
actually receives an HTTP request and
when it actually is able to dispatch
that to a view function or a view class
is that there tends to be a lot of code
in between there and there are many
decisions that can be made that can
guide the direction of that code
differently this smart code often tends
to be very core to the to the operation
of the library it tends to be fairly
minimal in terms of where it is and it
also has a tendency to be very scattered
throughout the codebase so it may not be
easy to find that code sometimes I've
seen code bases and I struggle to even
figure out where the meat is it's all
bread or all you know pasta but the
little bits of meat inside are very
difficult to find
and so one of the things that I find
that's necessary is trying to figure out
how to find that
now there's another core dichotomy that
I've seen which is it's very difficult
for us to analyze smart code statically
it's just too complex
there's too much dispatch there's too
much knowledge there too many there's
too much states going on at the same
time and we often cannot analyze dumb
code statically because there's just too
much of it in in terms of the lines of
code there is we can't read through it
we might be able to apply some static
techniques but we won't see anything
that interesting and the interesting
patterns that we'd see there are not
particularly visible and unfortunately
trying to distinguish where the dumb
code and where the smart code is is also
very difficult I would encourage you to
take a library like matplotlib or numpy
if you've never looked at those
libraries before and actually try to
find out where the ndra
is defined that's the core of map numpy
I actually try to find out a matplotlib
where the draw a graph is generator and
how that's processed and that's also
very difficult to find in the depth of
all of the other functionality that
wraps you know these core data models
now when I say you need to find
something to run it obviously if there's
a test suite run it I'm part of the
reason to run a test suite is not to
have that foothold into runnable code
but also to set your expectations
because there is no guarantee for the
work product of a single person that the
test suite actually works I've seen test
Suites where the author didn't need to
run the test suite all the time so half
the tests fail because they haven't been
updated it was just too much effort for
them to do I imagine for your own work
product where you're not sharing this
code with anybody else or we don't
expect to share this code with anybody
else how often do you really write and
maintain and pay a lot of attention to
your tests especially if your actioning
requests for additional functionality at
a fairly pass pathway but you can set
expectations by at least telling your
boss look I can't do anything with this
code base test suite doesn't even run
ideally there's some sample code
somewhere and just being able to run
even a dumb sample app is useful ideally
there's also some production code that
you can run and you can see in its
operation if it's a if it's more of a
system or an application than a library
the idea here is you want to set a
baseline not only in terms of the
expectations that you're broad
to whoever you're responsible to for the
maintenance of that code but also to set
a baseline for the requirements for what
the code takes to run because it's very
often the case that you may not find
that you can just run this code in a DA
container in a virtual lab you may need
some very complex set of environment
environmental variables access to
database resources it may not be able to
be isolated a very good goal once you
have a foothold in this code base and
you're more comfortable once you've been
able to get it run in any fashion
whatsoever is to try to reduce the
runtime complexity of the context in
which it runs try to isolate the code as
much as possible because if you get the
code to run in a dock container with no
access to any other folders without
Network access with only a list of
enumerated requirements code library
requirements then it's gonna be a lot
easier for you to start to tease apart
that complexity a lot of very complex
code bases end up being complex because
they're reliant on state that's relying
on things that are not tracked in the
code itself in the requirements txt or
the requirements in or the set up top UI
additionally that runtime context is
very important because the only
effective way that you can really
understand what's gonna go what's going
on on a large Python code base is via
dynamic analysis and unless you have a
runtime context to throw your dynamic
instrumentation tools into you're not
gonna be able to get anywhere so one big
thing is what if the software is
data-driven been given large code bases
what are which are driver driven the
actual code base itself relies on some
data in order to determine the
modalities in the code base you're out
of luck here because a very data-driven
app it's written by a single person
unless you have a sample set of data
that exposes all the possible modalities
of that code base you're gonna have a
lot of difficulty really managing that
code base because you're not going to
know there's going to be functionality
that you won't be able to ascertain
actually exists until you see the sample
data this is the case where I've seen
cases where you have an application that
relies on an object database so people
are storing Python objects and some you
know no SQL object database those Python
objects are pickled so they have
functionality associated with them the
application might load
bunch of objects like imagine if it's a
finance a trading application and it has
a portfolio and each object represents a
single position in that portfolio and
each object has a price method well
unless you know what a sample portfolio
looks like you don't know what the price
methods look like you don't know what
the price method looks like you have no
idea what the actual extent of what that
code can actually do is and you'll never
be able to really get a hold on what's
happening so a really important question
is how do you find the smart part of the
code because you're given this enormous
code base you cannot read through 50,000
lines of code in a week unless it
happens to be exclusively dumb code and
the monotony of reading through 50,000
lines of code makes it very easy for you
to skip over the interesting or the
smart parts they just have your eyes all
to the back of your head and to just
kind of zone out while you're reading
through it so a very important thing is
how do you find the smart part and
another important question is why is it
important to analyze this code base
dynamically why is it difficult to
analyze it statically so to start with
let's think about some very simple
static analysis techniques when I was
coming together with when I was putting
this talk together I asked a couple of
my colleagues who are core developers at
different Python libraries some of the
techniques or tools that they've used
and I asked them for some of the static
techniques they've use and from the
dynamic techniques they've used a very
simple static technique is what we saw
before just run see lock to figure out
what what what languages are used in
this code base how much of this is
Python how much of this is C if you run
that on something like matplotlib you'll
see there's portions of that code that
aren't fortran there's portions of that
code that are in c for the most part if
you were inaugurated as the BD FL of
matplotlib it may be the case at that C
code or that Fortran code is so old has
been around for so long you probably
don't have to look at it immediately you
may only eventually have to look at it
you might want to focus your attention
on the parts that are more user facing
which would be the Python code similarly
if you see a code base there's a lot of
HTML or CSS you can narrow yourself and
start to whittle down how much of that
code you actually care about another
approach would be you know one person
said just take all the code print it out
and just sort it by the lines and you
may begin to see certain patterns if you
look at a single line and just sort by
what's the most common line I ran this
on matplotlib the most common line was
an empty line then there was
a couple of documentation lines that
were very common doesn't give you a
whole lot of information for a library
but imagine you have an application
where certain function calls are called
over and over again or maybe it's a
library where you have users who are
writing little scripts or plug-ins for
that you'll start to see common lines
like database access like setting up the
context and you'll begin to see a couple
of hints about what the general pattern
is it's not that useful of a tool unless
the code base is written in a very
repetitive fashion another approach
might be you know just take every every
file split it onwards and find the most
common words because you can think if
the code base was written very
statically and there's a bunch of
function calls and it's always just from
module import function a and there's a
bunch of lines that say call function a
call function a call function a you can
at least find what are commonly called
functions again in library type code
this is not that useful because if you
think about the way that that code would
be written if people were repeatedly
calling the same set of functions in the
same order somebody's going to add an
abstraction where that's extracted out
in order to minimize the amount of
repetition we're told as programmers
don't repeat yourself and we're told
that this normalization of our code
makes it easier to maintain and so the
desire to normalize our code and to not
repeat ourselves ends up defying our
ability to analyze it statically now we
can improve the static analysis better
by you know doing things like using
pythons tokenized module to actually
tokenize the code if you do that you
need to do something a little bit more
sophisticated keywords or remove
punctuation and if you do that you can
at least find certain general themes of
the codebase like for example what
variable names are used often when I ran
this on matplotlib I found a couple of
variable names referring to you know our
C params comes up as one of the most
common tokens and matplotlib and for
those of us who are matplotlib users we
can kind of understand why that would be
does it give us that much insight into
the code no but it gives us a little bit
of a foothold cause on the boss-ass so
it's been one week where are you you can
say well I know our C params is really
interesting I don't know how useful that
will be but it gives you a little bit of
a foothold as to try to understand
what's important or what's common
ideally if this code base is very static
that might you might see in the most
common list of that common function
names or common
module names percolate to the top but
you might have to do a lot more
filtering and if you think about the
output of this if you look at the first
200 items might take you an hour but you
might it might give you something that's
worth grabbing for so these static
unfortunately where we're guided as
programmers is to defy the ability to
statically analyze our code so we need
to have some techniques in order to
dynamically analyze our code and this
tends to be much harder to do in Python
that it is to do in Java or C I want to
go through just a couple of simple
techniques that I've used in order to
static in order to dynamically analyze
code now at first we can talk about
these as what you might call
instrumentation mechanisms mechanisms
which take some code and add a little
bit of information you have some context
which you can run this code either
sample code a test suite or a production
code in many cases if the production
code is doing a lot like it's some kind
of high-frequency mechanism that's
responding to requests very quickly the
amount of output that you generate from
these instrumentation mechanisms may not
be understandable by human being so you
might have to take that output and then
apply both data analysis techniques to
it like generating histograms what's the
most common output or writing analysis
tools to actually analyze the output of
your instrumentation that is not that
uncommon but let's assume at least for
the purposes of looking through these
instrumentation mechanisms that the
output of these are within what you can
look at in an afternoon and understand
as a human being without applying
another metal layer of instrumentation
analysis a very simple thing that people
might do is you might start with very
holistic instrumentation like you could
use a tool like s trace and try to find
what are all the files that are opened
what are all the files that are touched
read written to by by your tool that at
least gives you an ability to try to
understand what the runtime context is
what configuration files does this look
at what you know there's a database or a
socket that's opened what what's touched
by this file what modules are touched by
this file where those modules are
located it's often the case that if this
has not been deployed correctly it may
be that the modules that are used by
this are not isolated into a condo
environment or a virtual environment but
they may be scattered wrong the file
system and you may end up looking at one
version of a library that you think is
being used and be misled because it's
actually stored somewhere else so this
could at least tell you generally where
all the files
this thing reads how useful is that well
it gives you at least one baseline to
figure out what the runtime context is
if you want to figure out what the
runtime context is another thing that I
see in complex code bases is they'll
make use of environmental variables
those environmental variables will
determine how the thing runs it won't
just be things that are passed into the
on the command line and so you can
always go into the OS module and just
patch out OS dot and vairam and you
could see what environmental variables
are actually being looked at think about
a code base that that you've run where
it has like a UAT a QA and a production
environment there may be environmental
variables that cause modalities in that
code base that cause you to follow one
code path or another unless you can
actually figure out what the
environmental variables that are
actually looked at you'll never be able
to parse down you're not be able to pair
down the the runtime context for many of
these apps it's like a shell script that
set some environment to variables that
calls another shell script that calls
another shell script that finally calls
a Python system if you can at least
track at the end what those
environmental variables are you might be
able to start paring down the execution
context so you can I eventually isolate
it into a docker container so you can
have some fixed boundary around what
this thing does or what this thing
touches it what's that
you know another dynamic approach you
might use Python is actually full of
dynamic analysis techniques and tools
for that so another approach Python and
the Syst module has a line tracer we can
do a set trace one thing that I've done
is you do a set trace you run your test
suite you you create a histogram of
every filename and every line number
that's touched think about this the
static analysis technique where you do a
sorting on the lines of code that you
see or you do a tokenizing and a
histogram on the tokenizing that's gonna
mislead you because if somebody has
refactored that code suddenly something
that's touched a hundred times has now
only touched five times because there's
now some layer of abstraction that
reduces the repetition however in a
runtime context that repetition still
exists and so if you look at every line
of code that's executed as part of the
execution of your test suite you might
actually able to find out where the
hotspots are you can see oh when I run
my test suite of a thousand lines of
code you know this one particular line
of code in this one particular module
gets called 50,000 times so that's
probably close to where the interesting
part of that code is or you
can start to graph out more or less what
modules are interesting what files are
interesting and what lines are
interesting you could do the same thing
at just looking at the file name or just
looking at the package or the module if
you do this for so I did this for Matt
plot live with a very simple PI plot
histogram to try and see what that would
give me and I was able to pick out
certain parts of matplotlib that I
didn't know where that interesting where
those lines of code were being executed
10,000 times for actually not 10,000
lines but like 50 or 60 times for just a
simple execution of a simple graph now
the information that I was able to glean
from that did not give me more
information to understand how Matt
public work but if I ran it over the
entire test suite I might see certain
certain areas like you know general
configuration dispatchers which every
piece of code goes through and those
will start to percolate towards the top
and it'll give me a little bit more of
an indication of where I need to start
looking by the way we haven't even
gotten to maintaining it we're still
trying to figure out where to look this
is what happens when you're put into
this situation you don't even know where
to start
now another technique that I have
employed successfully is you know in
Python you have system meta paths where
you can insert into Python hooks that
hook into the import mechanism what I've
done before is I've used Network X and a
custom meta in Port hook in order to
what the import up does very simple
every time Python tries to import a
module my import hook says yeah I can
import it internal to that import hook
it just reinforce the importing
mechanism and it keeps track of what
imported what importer what this
actually works surprisingly well in
Python because the importing mechanism
of Python has a lock around it so it's
impossible for multi-threaded code to
actually to actually call this thing in
parallel and so you have you can write
some fairly simple it's about 20 lines
of code
fairly simple mechanisms that assume
everything is single threaded
irrespective how the application
actually runs that constructs a graph of
this module imports this module imports
this module import this module when I
did that I began to see in that
application one module that everything
imported and that was a place where I
wanted to start looking because if you
think about our application code it's
often the case that if it's written well
there's some core and it's a
hub-and-spoke model where
some core is used by everybody and then
everything's kind of a spoke off of it
however if you do that and you see a
spiderweb where there's no one place
where everybody convenes then you really
know you better hurry up in your job
search because this is gonna be a real
mess and it's not unusual for codebases
to end up with that pathological case of
this it's no longer a hub-and-spoke with
just a web where everything imports
everything and it's difficult to
identify what the core part of that
module is there are other tools there's
quite a few tools that you can download
one of them that I like is object graph
object graph you can give it a Python
object and it'll actually graph the
references for that Python object so for
example if it's a data-driven
application you might be able to take
one of the pieces of data that's driving
the modalities in that program ask for
the pythons GC module actually be able
to tell you this object holds a
reference onto these objects and these
objects hold our reference for this
object so you take one of the one of the
data items that you have and you can see
who's holding a reference and you'll
begin to see some of the collection
structuring so in a financial example if
you're trying to figure out how a
portfolio analysis tool works you might
start with a single position and you'll
see from that well there's a portfolio
that holds a reference on to the
position there's some a larger object
larger object large orbit and a GUI
program you might see some modal dialog
is held by some windows held by someone
or some held by some window and it'll
give you an idea of the structuring of
the project because remember at this
50,000 line of code middle ground it's
very possible that the code is not well
structured there may be some structuring
to the code base but it may not actually
reflect how the code base works at
500,000 lines or five million lines that
starts to become untenable because new
people can't be onward onto the project
and figure out where things are but at
the 50,000 line of code base it's very
possible in your mind to just remember
where all the interesting part is and it
doesn't have to be reflected in the code
structure the problem is all of these
techniques may then require further
analyses and so instead of actually
looking at this information itself one
thing that I always do is I always try
and log it to disk because you can
generate megabytes and megabytes and
megabytes information from the line
profiler because it's telling you every
single line that's run here I've you to
histogram of it which is a compression
information instead of generating the
histogram directly if you just log every
line and you have the ordering there and
you know that it's a single-threaded
application then you might be able to do
larger window analysis remember the
histogram is only looking at one data
item at a time imagine once you have
this on this you might say well what are
what are bike and think about it you
could what are buy grams of function
calls or lines that are called
in some fashion so you can start to
apply some of the analysis techniques
that you're used to for the actual work
that you're doing to the code finding
which two function calls are likely to
appear you might even create a machine
learning model given this line of code
what's the most likely line of code to
follow it what would that tell you I
don't know but it might tell you
something kind of interesting and at
worst it'll be a really cool PI a to
talk that'll help you find that next job
so one thing that I often used to try
when I was given these kind of code
bases is try to find the entry point I
am very much on the fence about how
useful it is to find the entry point of
an application it's useful in one
context if you have the time it's very
useful to find it because if you can
find the entry point of a Python
application as in wherever the main
function is or where the thing is
launched from it can very much help you
with some dynamic instrumentation
techniques where you need to inject or
wrap something and you need to make sure
that you're injecting or wrapping code
occurs first and the execution of the
program otherwise finding the entry
point and trying to trace the entry
point to the interesting parts of the
code base is a is you can start going
down rabbit holes and I've wasted so
much time going down that rabbit hole of
here's the main function here's what a
calls here's what a calls here's what a
calls oh now I need to know some dynamic
input to figure out where it goes next
and then the number of possibilities
those modalities explode however if you
have the if you have the the entry point
you might be able to do some injection
or wrapping that allow you to find that
allow you to inject instrumentation to
find the the core functionality so one
of the other questions I heard was how
do we find the functionality here who's
impressed I'm still holding on to the
conceit that we started 35 minutes ago
get into a debugger so because you have
to analyze this code dynamically yes you
could emit print statements or logging
statements and then subject those to
to a panda's data frame position some
analysis but oftentimes that smart code
the code that you care about is small
enough that you just want to find it and
it's difficult to find it sometimes I've
I've signed myself up for like lightning
talks where I promise to make this
change or that change in the Python
interpreter without actually knowing
where that code is in the Python
interpreter Python interpreter is about
from memory about 150,000 lines of C and
Python code altogether so it's a fairly
large code base it's well designed and
it's well laid out but even then it's
difficult to find things for the talk I
did on Thursday one of the things I
wanted to find was where the Python
interpreter performed nfk D
normalization on tokens so I could patch
that out and I asked one of the core
developers who was there at the
conference and he didn't know off the
top of his head so I had to use
debugging techniques to try to find a
point which would allow me to trace
where in the interpreter the code is
that perform that action there's a
couple of things you can do if you're
using Python 3.7 there's a new break
point function that's been added in
Python 3.7 that will drop you into
debugger so if you can find some code
and you just type breakpoint as a
function you can actually drop yourself
into debugger wouldn't it be amazing if
the horrible code base you were given
happen to also be up-to-date with all of
the libraries and all the versions of
Python so maybe this is a little bit
speculative because there's a very good
chance of this terrible code base we're
talking about is written in Python 2.6
and if you use Python to point six point
two it breaks for some unknown reason
and it's using some version of
matplotlib that was only released on one
platform fifteen years ago that's a
possibility there's a couple of other
tools that have been in Python for a
very long time the PDB module gives you
a debugger there's post-mortem if you
can find the entry point one of the
things you can try doing is triggering
the code to fail rap-rap the entry point
and a try except once you get into the
except after you're triggered to fail
maybe by doing ctrl C to kill it to
raise a keyboard error if to kill it the
post-mortem will launch PDB into
something where you can go up and down
the back trace to figure out where you
killed it so run the application so
instrument the entry point or create a
new entry point that launches into the
original entry point instrument that
with try accept post-mortem find some
way to kill the application and
you get a back-trace that tells you at
least the the stack trace of where you
are and it might give you an indication
of where to look next in order to find
where some functionality occurs
similarly PDP also has set trace so if
you have the ability if you kind of know
something adjacent to the interesting
part of the code just say from PDP in
port set trace and call set trace but
PDP is a pretty weak tool sometimes what
I've done is in the code module in
Python in the standard library there's
something called interactive console you
can use interactive console to actually
drop your code into an interactive
console just like you type to python in
the command line and it's about four
lines of code i've done this off enough
i can type these from memory and what
you can do is you find an interesting
part of the code base your drop into an
interactive console it's not as rich as
pd because you can't go up and down the
stack trace to figure out where this was
called from you can't see that you can
use the inspect module to do some of
those things but this gives you an
interactive console so you can start to
do things like try to mutate the current
state instead of here this is taking a
copy of the Global's and locals but if
you just take the original locals you
can mutate that state and see what
happens one of the techniques that I
used to do in C code all the time is
instrument C code with just something
looks like this interrupt three is
trapped two debugger so I'd run my C
code under a debugger trap the debugger
at the interesting point and that would
give me just enough of a hook where I'm
in the debugger at a point which I kind
of knows something about I can see the
back trace and from the back trace I can
see where's the next place where I'm
gonna try and put this debugger hook you
can do the same thing in Python using
the signal module and OS so if you add
these three lines you'll actually trap
two debugger the problem is in a normal
run of Python this is just gonna cause
the Python program to seg fault
it'll just cord up for you so what you
need to do is you need to be running
Python under a debugger in order for
this to work however unfortunately these
techniques are kind of invasive and all
of these kind of presume that you have
the ability to take the code base and to
change it imagine this code base is
deployed we have some production
deployment mechanism so you can't really
just deploy code into production that
has breakpoints all over the place and
so if you don't have the ability to
invasively change the code by adding you
know from PDB import set trace all over
the place or adding break
statements you're a little bit limited
there are a couple of techniques you can
you can approach that are similar to
this unfortunately one of the major
limitations is Python has no ability to
create what you might call a pure proxy
you can't take a data item in Python and
wrap it in something else either via
composition or inheritance to make it a
pure proxy one of the reasons for that
is if you have like a subclass of the
type of object that you have somebody
could have done type X is and you can't
fake that on the Python without going to
the sea level so in the absence of a
pure proxy the most you can do in Python
is subclass something implement those
underscore methods and try to capture
accesses like I did in the previous
slide with my OS not environ this is
just about the best you can do in Python
you can't just completely fake out an
object in order to catch where that
works I've had this happen before where
one piece of data and a large data
driven pipeline application was causing
the application to terminate I didn't
know which it was I tried to load all
the data that I knew the program was
going to use I wrapped them in proxy
objects and then I saw the moment one of
those proxy objects had a method called
on it in order to figure out where in
the codebase the method was being called
that was causing an exception in the
code base like a division error because
my trace backs were because this was
embedded in a runtime context where I
couldn't see the trace back and I
couldn't get any debugging information I
need to do this myself there are some
significant limits to what you can do
with that but it's at least a good start
now one thing that you could do none of
this code still works but a while back
as a joke I created a module called our
watch what our watch allows you to do is
allows you to put a hook on the Python
internal virtual machine every time a
variable is pushed to the Python
internal stack so every time pure Python
code is going to look at a variable you
can put a breakpoint it looks something
like this where you you can basically
tell Python every time you run a python
instruction that's going to look at a
variable
give me a breakpoint unfortunate this
code is not maintained but this is one
approach where you can actually start to
try to get something akin to a pure
proxy and to debug these situations
where you have where you have
data-driven applications that just don't
work or where one piece of data is kind
of gumming up the works now one other
thing that you could do similar to the
debugging trick is you could in your
entry point register a trap Handler and
so you could tell Python when I get a
cig trap like when somebody sends that
kill signal to me I go into this handler
and that would allow you to have at
least one point where you could then use
the inspect module to get the current
frames and the outer frames and then
external to the program you just do kill
trap on the pit for the program what you
do in that case is inside that inside
that handler that you registered you'd
use the inspect module current frame and
get outer frames to figure out what
their back trace is or to figure what
the stack what the track frames led you
to that point and you'll be able to get
a little bit information about where you
are in the program and what's going on
one thing that I've done is I've run
pure Python applications under gdb and
then just control C which would trap to
my debugger this can be helpful because
from the debugger I could put
breakpoints but I can only put
breakpoints on C code so this is only
really useful if I'm trying to debug
some Python application that is a Seikh
dimension or a c component to it and a
python component and I'm trying to
figure out what's happening on the
boundary between both of those but you
could use this to maybe try to find the
entry point if in C you do a break on
them on main and figure out where the
main is implemented this is one of the
first things I did in Python to figure
out where the main function for Python
is implemented it's in Python run dot C
I believe no it's in the program's
directory under Python dot C now I can't
remember but what you could do is you
could use gdb to break on like PI eval
eval frame X and in the Python standard
in a source distribution of Python there
is a set of gdb macros under tools gdb
Lib Python that allow you to start to
introspect from gdb the Python layer so
you can see from a gdb sea level stack
trace what are the actual Python
functions that got called and that can
start to give you some information about
what the frames were evaluated and where
you are this is a very advanced
technique that you would only use if you
had a Python application that called in
to see them and called it the Python
that's not that unusual for data science
code
so I think one of the last things that
we might think is how do we avoid
inflicting this pain upon others and I
think that all of these different
techniques is grab back up take
different techniques in this general
discussion kind of leads us to a couple
of takeaways in terms of how do we avoid
this problem make it easy to run if
you're writing code make it easy for
somebody to just run what that means is
create test code and make sure that test
code is up to date because that test
code is how they're going to exercise
the function out of your program in
order to get a hook into that program to
be able to find where things are even if
you don't document this is the part of
the module that's interesting this is
where the core is if you can at least
run it they can at least start to use
some of these dynamic analysis
techniques to try and figure out where
things are if not test code give them
sample code and make sure you keep it up
to date because that can also help them
exercise the modalities the modules the
functions that are used in this code
base and see how they enter how they are
structured and how they interrelate with
each other if it's a data driven
application please give them sample data
because a lot of the complexity and the
functionality of that application may be
hidden in the data that's used to drive
the application if you only provide them
the code but you don't provide them
sample data they may have no ability to
really understand what's going on make
your code runnable in the most isolated
circumstance possible ideally in some
docker container using some default
version of like Ubuntu LTS with no
network access without access to a
without access to any shared folders so
that they can isolate what it is that
this program needs in order to run
because in the absence of that they're
gonna find it difficult to even get
started with your codebase to find a way
to run the thing because oh it needs
this config file in this directory it
needs access to the network in this
place it it loads this from the database
much less before they even try and
figure out what modules I have to
install to get this thing to run ideally
make your code in portable as a module
I've seen many code bases were the only
way to actually get a runtime context is
to run the application by calling it the
command line if you're gonna write your
code make it importa Balazs a module so
somebody from inside and interactive
console can just import your code and
start to play around with small pieces
of it
because when you when your code is only
runnable as a full program that
immediately requires that they start to
isolate the functionality of that down
to this function with this data produces
this result if you make it importa
Balazs a module then they can just start
importing pieces of the codebase and
immediately get down to they can whittle
down what they have to care about to
just one piece of your codebase we
talked about you know flat is better
than nested in the structuring of your
program you really want to have a fairly
flat structuring for your program or a
hub-and-spoke because otherwise when
they start to look at the stack frame so
the trace packs for that program they're
gonna find that the trace back where
some configuration parameter used is
here and then parallel to that there's
some trace back there's some some cut
out there's some code path that set the
environment to where the variable and
the further up that is and the deeper
that is where the two of these code
paths could join the harder is for them
to understand so what you want is a very
flat code base where there's one
controller that calls a bunch of stuff
they can see in that controller oh load
this configuration get this user input
and then actually perform some operation
on that and ideally there's some
centralized hub where everything is run
from and you're not going down you know
50 frames deep before the code is
actually in its main loop where it's
trying to perform the core of the action
don't bother writing out documentation
like nobody's gonna do it like I could
tell you to write documentation don't
even bother
but asserts there's start name this the
assert statement of Python can be
alighted from running Python code if you
run Python with a - capital o a stirrup
statements get alighted from the ast in
fact if you use the debug variable with
200 scores before and after if you have
a line that says if debug that code
branch actually gets alighted it gets
removed as part of the parsing of your
Python code so instead of writing
assertions I start instead of writing
documentation at least put a couple of
assertions there so that somebody
reading through your code can say well
they said assert X is greater than 0
that's not going to be part of a runtime
check but at least at this point in the
at this point in this code I can assume
that X is greater than 0 because if they
were running this in a non optimized -
oh context the thing would have failed
and so you can start to get
people the ability to constrain how many
possibilities they have to consider when
they read through your code by adding
assert so at the minimum if you're not
going to write documentation and don't
bother because nobody's gonna read it
anyway
use asserts as a form of documentation
or use the if debug trick to put to put
into your code expectations that
somebody reading through it can use in
order to limit how much they have to
keep in their head when they're trying
to understand your codebase and so among
all of those I hope you now have a
little bit more of a tool set for trying
to understand this problem this is a
very deep and complex problem any one of
these techniques we go into in great
depth I hope that was interesting to you
and I hope it gave you a couple of
techniques and some guidance and how to
maybe avoid inflicting this pain upon
your co-workers but you know what why do
you care you're leaving the company
anyway thank you so much I think we're
out of time for any real questions did
anyone have any real questions whose
actually had this happen to you before
really no a bunch of you have never been
given some work process that it wasn't
documented wasn't tested and now it's
your responsibility what do any any any
techniques that you used here that might
be of relevance to the rest of the
audience
absolutely and we can also see something
about the world which is some people
like David here are the kind of people
who drive down the street and I get
every green light and some of those of
you who raised your hands are the kind
of people who get every red lights so
you're always the one who receives the
code that David wrote any other comments
[Music]
really that and that and that's good
because when I when I leave places and
they asked me to hand over my work to
somebody else I always give them wrong
documentation just as ticket to them but
if you videotape me then you catch me
with that but that's if that's
everything Andy yeah as
[Music]
that would be that would be amazing but
I think what happened two people leave
organizations is their email inbox just
disappears and so all the conversations
nobody records those conversations
nobody when I've been given these code
bases often times I've been told oh
here's a thread where people talked
about it and the thread has two comments
and three links and it's really
unfortunate so maybe maybe part of the
cases if you're building a codebase
you're building something you have an
inbox where you can just CC in important
relevant email threads for later
archiving because it's it's absolutely
the case when you leave an organization
all your stuff gets archived you know in
case the SEC is coming looking for it
but nobody else has ever ever has a
chance to look
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely has anyone hiring yeah that's
a problem you're handing it off you
might generate reams of documentation
that the next person just ignores
because it's so often that it's not
useful at all okay I think we have time
for one more question or one more
comment and the problem with Python is
sometimes you can't put the the
breakpoints assume that you have a
physical point but what if you're trying
to put a breakpoint on a code that's
tight on a function is dynamically
created through some other process you
can't put a breakpoint in the idea on
that okay I think that's all we have
time for we might have run a little bit
over time but thank you so much
[Applause]